okay, so we already covered the facts of Donald
Trump's impeachment.
Impeached on two articles, article one and
article two passing by 200 with 230 and 229
votes in the house respectively last night.
Now there have been predictions for a while
that getting impeached would transform Donald
Trump into the most erratic version of himself.
And those predictions have come true.
He was in rare form yesterday tweeting all
day the white house said he was going to have
a busy day working.
He tweeted all day, dozens and dozens of tweets,
endlessly, some misspelled, many with random
capitalization of words in the middle of sentences,
all riddled with erratic on hinged lies.
It was not a good day for Donald Trump by
the time he showed up at a rally last night
in Michigan.
I don't have video today, but check it out
redder than we have ever seen him.
Uh, falling apart, coming unglued, seeming
to have, those are the shush problems.
Sure should alum the and all that stuff are
really very strange.
Rally last night, Trump tweeting to kick things
off yesterday morning.
Can you believe that I will be impeached today
by the radical left.
Do nothing.
Democrats and I did nothing wrong, a terrible
thing.
Read the transcripts, this show oiled and
never happen to another president again.
Say a prayer.
Trump show oiled himself on that tweet and
ultimately, uh, deleted it and correctly spelled
should Trump continuing to tweet all day,
furiously re tweeting right-wing Ajit trash
and propaganda, disinformation as well as
his completely misguided understandings of
even what was going on.
I was thinking, uh, Trump obviously is furious
and he of course doesn't like what's going
on, but he doesn't understand a lot of things.
He's probably sitting around even confused
as he watches hearings and the debate about
what's going on.
Uh, but remember, impeachment is not a normal
thing.
Only three presidents, including Trump, have
been impeached.
Donald Trump's behavior is not the behavior
of an innocent person.
A Trump continuing later tweeting a whacked
out all capital letters, tweets, saying, quote
such atrocious lies by the radical left do
nothing.
Democrats.
This is an assault on America and an assault
on the Republican party.
Now the, this is so funny, the upside of Trump
tweeting in all caps is that it prevents him
from erroneously capitalizing words randomly,
uh, just the first letter as he typically
does in his tweets.
You solve that problem by going all caps.
It unfortunately makes you look even more
erratic and unhinged.
And then Donald Trump giving his take on what
will happen, which seems to contain a possible
triple negative.
This is Trump attempting to quote a guy named
Andy McCarthy, of course, from Fox news.
Can anybody parse the grammar here?
Trump says in the end here, nothing happened.
We don't approach anything like the egregious
conduct that should be necessary before a
president should be removed from office.
I believe that a president can't be removed
from office if there is no reasonable possibility
that the Senate won't convict and remove the
president can't be removed if there is no
reasonable possibility of the Senate not convicting.
Maybe my English is my second language, I
admit, but something seems a little wacky
with those negations.
This probably gives you a sense of what was
going on yesterday.
An erratic, unhinged, and maybe even scared
individual.
This is a historic presidency.
We've seen everything from Donald Trump pushing
world leaders out of the way to be up front
during the photo op to seeing Donald Trump
hand draw with a Sharpie, a more politically
convenient weather map for a hurricane and
all sorts of corruption, cronyism and bribery
in between.
I do have to agree with Donald Trump.
In one sense, this never should have happened
in the sense that it shouldn't have been possible
for this to happen in the sense that Trump
never should've been president to begin with,
but that ship has long sailed.
This is where we are innocent people don't
go crazy like this.
He's going crazy.
This is the meme of old man yells at cloud
personified on Twitter every single day and
once again, I'm not being negative or positive,
I'm just being realistic.
He will probably get away with it when the
Senate acquits and then it will be up to you
and me and particularly voters in those key
States.
That made a difference in 2016 to decide because
it's really a decision if we go out to vote.
Half the country doesn't normally vote.
If we go out to vote, we get to decide.
It is not going to be allowed to continue
for another four years.
We'll have more about this on the show's Instagram
page.
David David Pakman show is the show.
[inaudible]
the grant.
Follow us there and while you were there,
follow me at David dot pact, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com